Ship to address. Order now.
Usually ships
in four to six weeks?!
I can make my own towels
in four to six weeks!
Mayor. You have a visitor.
Not now, I'm having problems.
But Mayor, it's Jeff Bezos.
Founder and CEO of Amazon,
Jeff Bezos?
Yeah.
Okay, okay. Let him in.
Right on through here,
Mr. Bezos.
Mr. Bezos, how great
to see you again.
How have you been?
I wish I was doing better.
Please, Mayor, have a seat.
Oh, thank you.
I guess you're here
because of the strike.
We had a deal, Mayor.
You told me this town
would be the perfect place
for one
of our fulfillment centers.
And it has been!
It gave so many people jobs,
and I'm not really sure
why everyone is so ...
Disgruntled? Dissatisfied?
Unamused?
Would you like to know
why Amazon is so successful?
Because the customer
is all that matters.
Now orders are going unfulfilled
all over the state of Colorado.
That makes us look very bad.
It makes you look very bad.
Perhaps you should no longer
be a Prime member.
Please! I'm trying to get
everyone back to work.
I'm gonna do everything
that I can.
Then we have an understanding.
Good bye, Mayor.
If everyone stays unfulfilled,
it will be you
who pays the price.